vabbè io non volevo venire quando quando
quando è arrivata la proposta di
partecipare a questa giornata ho reagito
subito distinto proprio e ho detto no
non ci posso andare non è una cosa per
me io sono una che sta sempre in regia
magari si preoccupa delle luci per gli
altri ma stare io sotto i riflettori è
un azzardo e francamente anche un
rischio inutile poi prima di
formalizzare il nome di
fingere una fuga dalla città
ho pensato di farmi un giro sul sito
dell'organizzazione e lì sono rimasta
colpita col pizzo e proprio fulminato da
una conversazione del 2010 di cui è
protagonista una ricercatrice americana
premier brown
ho sentito i profumi e mi chiamava mi è
venuto in mente la scena dei biscotti al
cioccolato di snoopy snoopy dice che lo
stanno chiamando anche se la porte
sbarrate i barattoli sono sigillati
questa conversazione si intitola il
potere della vulnerabilità sono andata a
guardarla
cosa dice bran e brown breve brown dice
che dobbiamo abbracciare tutti la nostra
vulnerabilità
dobbiamo accettare le nostre
imperfezioni le nostre
debolezze quella sensazione di mancanza
di inadeguatezza che che davvero ci
portiamo sempre addosso ed andare così
nel mondo andarci compiendo quello che
lei dice un atto di dignità e di
coraggio assieme e vedrete sostiene che
in pochissimo tempo vi sentirete
trasformati e diventerete il carburante
infinito della vita quotidiana
diventerete fonte di decine e centinaia
di altri innovativi e creativi
insomma è evidente che alla fine ho
detto va bene abbracciamo questa
vulnerabilità e
andiamo a raccontare una storia e così
la storia che vi voglio raccontare
parte da questa immagine siamo al
corriere della sera sull albertini
riunione di redazione e il 1967 più o
meno quando sono nata io sto giusto
regalando un paio d'anni vedete vedete
se vedete schierati
tanti ragazzi in bianco e nero nella
prima fila a quelli seduti sono il
direttore alfio russo e i vicedirettori
alle
le loro spalle c'è la squadra degli
inviati che erano stati tutti convocati
quel giorno per dare il via a
un'inchiesta sull'italia e sull'europa
che effettivamente negli anni sessanta
poi ha fatto storia quello che c'è
dietro questa foto
insomma questa foto è la ragione per cui
quando io sono diventata vicedirettore
del corriere della sera nel 2009 grazie
a ferruccio de bortoli
mi sono sentito subito come se come mi
appendessero addosso un cartello pesante
sul quale c'era scritto primo vice
direttore donna della storia del
corriere della sera dal 1876 e noi che
questo non sia vero non fosse vero anzi
devo dirvi che prima di venire qui
sono andata a fare una ricerca
d'archivio contando direttori
vicedirettori condirettori dal 1876 al
2009 si sono succeduti circa 100 uomini
96 per l'esattezza pro me questa cosa
faceva impazzire perché gli altri
vicedirettori che erano stratico
nominati insieme a me venivano
presentati come esperto di economia e
responsabile dello sviluppo digitale del
di corriere.it coordinatore dei corsi
locali responsabile della politica della
redazione romana per me bastava una
definizione di genere primo vice
direttore femmina amy ha cominciato devo
dirvi un travaglio che è durato un paio
d'anni e che è avvenuto tutto avendo
alle spalle un signore gigantesco che ho
portato con me anche questa sera perché
ormai io e lui non ci separiamo più non
possiamo stare lontani e ve lo presento
questo ritratto gigantesco
ecco voi dovete immaginarmi perché più
che per un caso della fortuna questo
ritratto gigantesco del vecchio indro è
appeso alle mie spalle in redazione
sulla parete dietro la mia scrive
scrivanie e se questo quadro che enorme
venisse steso sul pavimento della mia
stanza la coprirebbe quasi tutta avendo
indro alle spalle ho cominciato
lentamente a scendere a patti un po con
questa cosa che ero il primo vice
direttore donne ogni volta li mettevano
questo sottotitolo sotto ea cercare un
equilibrio con tutte quelle parole che
per una ragazza ex ragazza nata nella
seconda metà degli anni sessanta non
sono state particolarmente significative
forse noi abbiamo vissuto
facendo leva su conquiste della
generazione precedente ma non creando
mai un rapporto strutturato con
movimenti femministi con gruppi di donne
organizzati e quella era la mia
situazione per un certo punto sapete che
è successo che mi sono detta ma perché
no perché non fare delle novità che che
rappresento probabilmente una cosa
divertente magari
un fucile a me alle giornalista del
corriere della sera e soprattutto alle
lettrici del corriere della sera
ed è così che ho preso questa decisione
di creare giocando con virginia woolf
una stanza tutta per noi
dati i tempi non poteva che essere una
stanza digitale e il 9 marzo 2011
abbiamo dato il via alla 27esima ora la
27esima ora è un blog multiautore perché
a questo strano nome per due ragioni la
prima è che all'inizio del 2011 era
stato pubblicato uno studio della camera
di commercio di milano
chi diceva che se tutte le cose che
fanno le donne in alcune fasi in
condizioni di multitasking venissero
stese in orizzontale si arriverebbe a 27
ore
la seconda ragione che mi piaceva
tantissimo la 25a ora di spike lee e
quindi è stata la 27esima ora siamo
partite come dicevo il 9 marzo 2011 con
un post che si intitolava 365 giornate
delle donne lei l'idea era di dire
subito non vogliamo celebrare una
giornata delle donne
una festa vogliamo raccontare 365
giornate delle donne e le vogliamo
raccontare
libere da ogni ideologia in una totale
libertà appunto di scambio di storie di
idee e di azioni senza limiti di tempo
di spazio e gli argomenti
siamo partite che eravamo in quindici ci
siamo ritrovate in 540 dal 9 marzo 2011
negli spazi della 27esima ora hanno
scritto 540 autori diversi
che vuol dire chiaramente quasi tutti i
giornalisti alle giornalisti del
corriere della sera
e poi
tantissimi collaboratori e
collaboratrici esperti ed esperte che
man mano abbiamo conosciuto e tantissimi
lettori e lettrici che ci hanno proprio
affidato pezzi delle loro vite
quasi sempre in una condivisione ironica
e
gioiosa allegra ma in alcuni casi anche
con contenuti molto profondi e
drammatici insomma è partito questo
grande flusso di storie di firme di
diversità un certo punto ci siamo detti
ma come sarà il pubblico della 27esima
ora andiamo a vedere chi ci legge
abbiamo scoperto una cosa abbastanza
interessante il pubblico di questo blog
che era nato al femminile con 15
giornalisti che io avevo scelto nella
nella redazione cercando di incrociare
storie diverse personali e professionali
il pubblico è al 42 per cento donna ma
il 58 per cento uomini con la differenza
che ci parla della xxvii ora poi c'è chi
dice l'ho letto visto commentato
eccetera
e al 70 per cento donna quindi vuol dire
che tantissimi uomini passano leggono
magari commentano coperti dall'anonimato
ma poi negano di averlo fatto
la seconda cosa sorprendente della
storia della 27esima ora che non abbiamo
mai litigato
io mi devo dire che quando è cominciata
quasi tutti nel giornale mi dicevano tu
sei ma thackray
uno spazio libero senza limiti di
argomento di tempo tra un gruppo non
gerarchico di giornalista e voi
litigherete in continuazione finirà chi
vi tirerete i capelli e mi è venuto in
mente un pezzo che un articolo molto
interessante che avevo letto sul
guardian che diceva quando due donne
cominciano a discutere di una cosa
partendo da opinioni diverse
c'è sempre qualcuno che si immagina che
prima o poi cominceranno a tirarsi
dietro i tampax e invece sinceramente no
né nel nostro dei nostri due anni e
mezzo di storia non ci sono stati tampax
e non ci sono state risse e tutti questi
numeri tutti questi numero ne stanno
seduti su un numero gigantesco che 0 la
27esima ora è nata come una
sperimentazione a budget zero ed è
rimasta senza fondi chiunque scriva
mandi video van di informazioni e
fotografie al blog star che non riceverà
alcun contributo è una vera piazza
aperta virtuale reale molto molto libera
adesso vi racconto quattro cose che
abbiamo fatto dal 9 marzo 2011
ieri sera la prima cosa è stata andare
all'aquila
siamo andati a l'aquila e abbiamo
ho cercato di raccogliere le storie di
27 donne aquilane che abbiamo chiamato
affettuosamente le resistenti a l'aquila
il centro storico è ancora chiuso e
pattugliate dall'esercito
il rischio è chiaramente di una
depressione cittadina spaventosa perché
immaginatemi che i cinema le scuole i
teatri sono tutti come bombardati ancora
questo gruppo di donne ha cercato di
tenere ancora vivo il cuore della città
di non far disperdere una sensazione di
orgoglio di cittadinanza e qui abbiamo
raccolto le loro storie in quello che è
stato un docu web
questo esperimento di documentario
d'inchiesta pensata per il digitale
un'altra delle cose grandi che abbiamo
lavorato in questi anni è stata la
questione della violenza sulle donne
in questo caso invece siamo partiti in
modo molto tradizionale un'inchiesta in
nove puntate pubblicata su quotidiano
sul corriere della sera che poi è
diventata un libro questo non è amore
che è un libro molto fortunato perché
vende bene
e i nostri ricavi vanno tutti alle donne
aquilane e perché ha reso fortunato e
noi che siamo state veramente
protagonista di un viaggio straordinario
nel paese siamo andate a portarlo nelle
scuole nelle librerie
nelle sale municipali al senato della
repubblica e abbiamo veramente condiviso
un'esperienza anche fisica di dolore e
di superamento del dolore perché abbiamo
sempre cercato di raccontare le storie
di chi riusciva a chiudere la porta di
quelle case dove subiva violenza però
non abbiamo sempre parlato di cose
grandi come la violenza sulle donne o le
storie delle nostre amiche dell'aquila
moltissimi dei post più discussi e
commentati sono quelle che sono quelli
che hanno a che fare con le cose della
vita come disse eros ramazzotti una
volta la versione cose della vita la
proposta di anche a claudio magris che
trovò quest idea di eros straordinaria
per definire davvero tutti i nostri
piccoli drammi quotidiani uno dei post
che storicamente sta tra i cinque più
letti e commentati e questo il tempo di
noi single non vale meno di quello di
voi mamme che cosa era successo
era successo che la sera prima per una
delle solite emergenze che capitano nei
quotidiani era stato chiesto ad alcune
colleghe single di fermarsi oltre
l'orario per permettere alle giornaliste
mamme di correre a casa a preoccuparsi
dei figli e una di queste single
trattenute in redazione va detto ragazzi
se andiamo avanti così però io sarò
single per sempre perché non vi troverò
mai un uomo non faremo mai insieme un
figlio
e questo e per darvi un'idea
dell'alternanza dei temi che secondo me
è veramente fa parte della vita e quindi
fa parte del blog
in questa ricerca di elaborazione delle
nostre imperfezioni quotidiane abbiamo
fatto un altro incontro importante un
personaggio che ho voluto portare qui
anche in questo caso la vediamo insieme
speriamo che la riconoscete buongiorno
salve a tutti mi chiamo chiara
quest'anno le carte scusa ma scusate
spero che riusciate a sentirmi ma non ci
conosciamo
io mi chiamo chiara ciao tutto bene che
ci fa il pd a quest'ora ma no niente
contro l'avola posta arrivo ecco questa
è chiara la nostra mamma imperfetta una
web fiction che è nata dall anima della
ventisettesima ora con ivan cotroneo che
è andata poi sulla rai che sarà natale
al cinema siete tutti invitati
che andrà poi all'estero perché i
diritti sono stati venduti alla disney
l'ultima cosa di cui vi parlo molto
rapidamente anche se dietro c'è una
provocazione che vi faccio vedere subito
e che abbiamo lanciato a novembre e
continueremo fino alla prossima
primavera del 2014 questo cartellone il
tempo delle donne in redazione come
avete visto mi hanno caricato di rosa e
questa è una provocazione perché io ho
bandito il rosa della 27esima ora a
favore del rosso ma adesso ce lo fa alle
spalle comunque la nostra idea è quella
di creare delle occasioni di incontro
per permettere di conoscere e di
conoscersi di partecipare perché la
nostra convinzione è che
in questo paese in particolare in italia
in questo momento bisognerebbe veramente
unire le forze per spingere verso un
cambiamento che ristagna da anni e sono
i nostri indici vari di misurazione
della modernità sono fermi dagli anni 80
e noi crediamo che le donne siano
un'occasione straordinaria di muovere
una leva e di muovere quel 50 per cento
dei talenti che sono stati eternamente
sottovalutati sottostimati
sottoutilizzati che qui e qui siamo
arrivati alla fine e siamo arrivati
molto vicini a brano e brown e io credo
che la storia di questo blog italiano
non sia così lontana dai territori della
vulnerabilità positivi positiva
descritta da rainer brown perché queste
tre cose abbiamo imparato in questo
lavoro dentro la 27esima ora la prima è
che davvero dovremmo abbracciare le
nostre vulnerabilità accettarle andare
nel mondo appunto come diceva lei con
coraggio e con dignità il coraggio e
quello che viene dalla lavorazione della
paura quindi è molto lontano dalla
spavalderia dall'arroganza che forse in
giro si vede di più la seconda cosa che
dovremmo
ricostruire delle relazioni di fiducia
fiducia tra persone a battere quella
scatola quella piramide di scatole rosa
azzurra dove vengono spinte le nostre
identità e dove noi stesse a volte
rifiutiamo le nostre identità di uomini
e di donne
la terza è di stare insieme senza
antagonismi niente antagonismi uomini
donne niente antagonismi donne tra donne
dimostriamo come dicevamo prima che i
contrasti sono la linfa vitale ma li
possiamo contenere senza andare ad
abbatterci le une con le altre che è un
tabù una cosa da buttare via uno spreco
straordinario di tempo e di energia e
poi l'ultima cosa l'ho imparata io ho
imparato che c'è una ragione di giorgio
gaber quando io non devo fare sentivo
gaver che diceva la libertà è
partecipazione in sembravo una frase un
po strana ci sono molte altre cose da
dire della libertà prima di gemellata
con la partecipazione e invece no la
ragione lui soprattutto per le donne non
c'è libertà senza partecipazione senza
entrare in tutti i luoghi dove vengono
prese le decisioni che poi decidono le
nostre vite
ed è per questo che adesso vi lascio con
le persone che partecipano con le
persone che fanno la 27esima ora
questa storia
non c'è
hi fi car è sempre al top